they're the unhealed heroes of Hollywood
stunt doubles from free falls of 50 feet
or more crashing through windows amazing
chase scenes and incredibly
choreographed fight done doubles make
most of the silver screens biggest
blockbusters possible here's a peek at
what they really look like and more
about their amazing stunt resumes cannel
I read is Dwayne the rock Johnson's The
Rock's cousin Tanima Reid has worked as
a stunt double in nearly 20 different
roles from 2002 as a Scorpion King to
2017 Baywatch Reid has been performing
stunts for his world-famous cuz in
addition to being practically as close
as brothers Reid and Johnson frequently
collaborate behind the scenes on aspects
of their combined performance Reid has
won two tourist world stunts awards over
the years for his work as well as
working as an actor and motion capture
performer for the 2011 video game Thor
god of thunder all Darnell is Robert
Pattinson for the last ten years Paul
Darnell has been working as a stuntman
but he's not busy competing in parkour
and freerunning competitions around the
world Darnell was inspired to start
freerunning and doing stunt work after
watching a 2003 episode of Ripley's
Believe It or Not which featured parkour
not only is he a talented stuntman but
Darnell has also been a two-time
finalist on the popular television
series American Ninja Warrior a former
gymnastics champion at Virginia Tech
Darnell has built up an impressive stunt
reel over the years for himself
including his work as a double for Henry
Cavill and Man of Steel Adam Sandler and
you don't mess with the Zohan Paul
Walker in Fast Five and Robert Pattinson
and Water for Elephants remember me and
the Twilight Saga a gig that Pattinson
thanked Darnell for when the film won
best fight at the MTV Movie Awards
Marnie Eng is Reese Witherspoon since
the early 1990s Canadian stunt woman
Marni yang has racked up more than 100
roles working as a stunt double and
stunt coordinator and has been twice
nominated for a tourist World stunt
award among many others she doubled for
dozens of women and men over the years
but the actress she's performed stunts
for most frequently have been Reese
Witherspoon
Ann has been a double in at least three
different roles including 2015 hot
pursuits Aang is also no stranger to
acting and you can spot her as Tabitha a
spoof of the character Samara from the
ring in the 2003 horror comedy scary
movie 3 Jack Gill is Will Ferrell
there's no question that the hilarious
nascar comedy Talladega Nights The
Ballad of Ricky Bobby required a lot of
fancy stunt driving and Jack
Gil is a man behind that action since
the 1970s Gil has worked as a Sun
performer and stunt driver on over 170
films and television shows including as
the primary Sun driver on both the Dukes
of Hazzard and Knight Rider we had a
good time of the show and it was one of
those one types of shows that was like a
family it's a really tight-knit group
over the years Gil has branched out into
stunt coordination and second-unit
directing including on several of the
Fast & Furious films with a metal plate
in his neck 23 broken bones and eight
concussions over the course of his four
decade career there's unquestionably
nobody more qualified than Gil to
testify about the difficulties of the
job Gil has also been instrumental in
the push among the son community for an
Oscar or two recognizing the
achievements of the stunt men and women
that make so many of today's movies
possible Luci Romberg is melissa
mccarthy for the last decade Luci
Romberg has been at the top of her game
as a stunt woman the Hollywood native is
a former champion gymnast and also
competes as one of the few females and
high-level freerunning competitions
around the world
[Music]
over the course of her career Romberg
has doubled for Melissa McCarthy several
times including an identity thief by the
boss and ghostbusters Greg Fitzpatrick
is Ben Stiller in the world of stunt
performers getting a job as the
preferred stunt man or woman for one of
Hollywood's top stars is the ultimate
gig for Greg Fitzpatrick that
opportunity came relatively early in his
career when he was picked as a stunt
double for Ben Stiller in the 2003 film
duplex since then greg has become the
preferred double / Stiller and has since
appeared in more than a dozen films as
Stiller stuntman in addition to his
resemblance to Ben Stiller Fitzpatrick
is also a talented stunt performer and
coordinator he's won two Taurus World
stunt Awards and doubled for Robert
Downey jr. in both Ironman and Ironman -
I'm so happy to be working in a to be
allowed to work in a business that I
love I just want to continue to do it
Vic Armstrong is Harrison Ford according
to the Guinness Book of World Records
Vic Armstrong Raines is the most
prolific stuntman in the world
additionally Armstrong is one of the few
stunt performers to ever break the
Academy Award barrier winning a
technical achievement Academy Award in
2001 with well over a hundred son
credits in a career that spans five
decades it probably wouldn't surprise
you to learn that Armstrong doubled for
some of Hollywood's biggest roles
including as James Bond Superman and
Indiana Jones like a lobby I'm not into
drugs or anything but when people talk
about a high would you do stunts you get
a natural highs I guarantee it nobody in
the world man reportedly crew members
frequently confused Armstrong with
Harrison Ford on the set of the Indiana
Jones films which resulted in Ford
sending Armstrong a photo of the two of
them with the humorous inscription if
you learn to talk I'm in deep trouble
Billy Lucas is Arnold Schwarzenegger
since the 1990s Total Recall stuntman
Billy Lucas has had the sweet gig of
working as Arnold Schwarzenegger stunt
double on the set of most of his films
from Kindergarten Cop to the Terminator
series if you saw Arnold do some crazy
action scenes it was most likely Lucas's
work that you were watching not Arnold
in addition to his role of
Schwarzenegger stunt-double Lucas has
worked on over a hundred different
movies and TV shows as a stunt performer
and coordinator
despite his undoubtedly busy schedule it
seems that Swardson digger and Lucas had
become close over the years the former
California Governor even shared a story
of how Lucas saved his life during a
risky scuba diving shot on the set of
the 6th day saying I was trapped then a
hand grabbed me and pulled me out
it was my stunt double Billy Lucas he
had been watching from below with the
tank and goggles and realized that was
in big big trouble
Randolph Laroy is Will Smith a Haitian
native who emigrated the Brookland as a
child
Randolph Laroy grew up playing sports
and training in Taekwondo as an adult
Laroy got involved in modeling and also
became a firefighter in Miami a spot as
mr. may on the fire department's
promotional calendar began to lanham
roles in commercials and TV spots in
Florida which prompted Laroy to moved to
California to try his hand at acting and
some performing after being picked as a
stunt double for Will Smith on 1995 bad
boys Laroy and Smith to become close
friends since then Leroy has doubled for
Smith on nearly a dozen films like in
2007 I am Legend Eddie and SiC is
Nicolas Cage only a few short years
after a stuntman debut in 1993 Eddie on
set got picked to be Nicolas Cage's
stunt double in the 1997 action film
Conair since then Yan SEC has doubled
for cage and more than a dozen roles
including lord of war matchstick men and
ghost riders in addition to his over 70
stunt credits over the last three
decades the inside has also worked as a
stunt coordinator actor and a second
unit director in 2001 Yan State
distinguished himself with this stunt
work when he won a Taurus Award for Best
driving for his performance in a gone in
60 seconds chase scene between a Mustang
and a police car Tony Angelotti is
Johnny death
Tony Angelotti is primarily known for
his work as Johnny Depp stunt double in
the Pirates of the Caribbean film
franchise a job you've held a
significant personal cost an accident on
the set of Dead Man's Chest in 2005
nearly ended his career and his life
while rehearsing a human yo-yo stunt
everything went drastically wrong
Oh oh my god Oh Kenny down the tension
on the line was incorrect and the
centrifugal force whipped him around so
hard that when Angelotti hit the end of
the line his pelvis was split apart like
a wishbone on a turkey it may not look
that bad but while prepping this
sequence Angelotti broke his pelvis
suffered injuries to his knees legs and
bladder and lost a massive 16 'its of
blood from internal bleeding but he
hasn't let his injuries keep him down he
doubled again for death in 2007 at
World's End and continues to work in the
Sun field today
Olivia Jackson is Mila Jovovich Olivia
Jackson's promising stunt career was cut
short in 2016 when she suffered a
near-fatal accident on the set of
resident evil the final chapter where
she was working as Mila Jovovich is
stunt double prior to a role in that
film Jackson had worked as a stunt
double for Charlize Theron in Mad Max
fury road and for Elizabeth Olsen in
Avengers age of Ultron in the horrific
accident the motorcycle ejection was
riding in a scene crashed into a camera
crane arm when it malfunctioned and
didn't move out of the way fast enough
Jackson was in a medically induced coma
for 17 days because of her injuries
which included serious facial trauma a
punctured lung a crushed arm which had
to be amputated and debilitating damage
to her spine and neck the accident
wouldn't be the only incident to plague
the set up Resident Evil not long after
Jackson's crash a crew member on the set
died when a Humvee slipped from a sling
and crushed him beneath for her part
Jackson is fighting bravely to move on
with their life and recently shared some
photos of herself on the road to
recovery thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]